pas monsieur canet bonsoir à vous
bonsoir félicitations pour votre
réélection
mais bon vous le voyez comment à quoi
vous attribuer cette défaite et cette
nette victoire des libéraux
évidemment un prêt dix 10 années
nous savions que il y améliorer une
volonté pour le changement cet éclair
dans l'élection et les électeurs qui
voulaient un changement ont regroupé
autour du parti libéral avec la chute de
leur pib
évidemment on a perdu l'appui une
certaine appuie depuis à la dernière
élection
pour moi notre gouvernement était une
bande gouvernement au clan de substance
des politiques de gestion fiscale et
économique
nous étions ne ne tient pas parfait mais
nous avons accompli nos attentes nous
avons gardé nos promesses mais je crois
que le gouvernement conservateur des
fois faisait les erreurs au niveau de
communication et de tonnes des fois nous
ne tient pas très bon ton pour
communiquer nos motifs apport politique
et je crois qu'il faut que le parti
conservateur à une moment de de
réflexion est-ce qu'on entre dès
maintenant dans une course au leadership
500 d'évident que me sens un peu va
annoncer sa démission tout à leur écoute
et on va attendre son annonce cesser ses
propos ce soir et prochainement
il y aura le temps à l'avenir pour le
parti conservateur le caucus et et les
parties à considérer ces questions là
mais se passe pour ce soir mais je
savais ce qu'est née que vous dites que
la campagne aurait pu être mené
différemment que le temps de la campagne
que l'explication de la campagne vous en
voulez un peu de la manière dont ça a
été fait ce pansement la campagne je
dirais que pendant toutes les années de
notre gouvernement nous aide nous avions
misère des fois à faire transmettre
notre message et il faut que nous
prenons il faut que nous prenions les
responsabilités possibles pas mettre le
blâme sur les médias c'est à nous autres
les conservateurs faire communiquer le
message positif
optimiste de nos progrès économiques de
réduction du fardeau fiscal est toutes
nos accomplissements je crois que c'est
un bilan positif mais qui n'étaient pas
toujours bien de communiquer parce qu'on
avait souvent l'impression que vous
étiez en guerre avec les médias que vous
étiez en guerre avec des gens qui ne
pensaient pas comme vous et peut-on
vraiment gouverner comme ça je suis
d'accord
bon vous êtes d'accord qu'il faut un
changement mais le disiez vous monsieur
canet vous avez le droit de parler dans
les réunions de cabinet le disiez vous
je n'ai pas par des des discussions au
sein du cabinet évidemment mais je
dirais que ce que c'est bien évident que
les consommateurs pouvaient faire une
meilleure démarche pour faire
communiquer notre message positif
puisque parce qu'ils écoutent et nous
avons des bilans de croissance
économique création d'emplois réduction
du fardeau fiscal meilleurs au monde
développé
on a passé de 5 57 ans tantôt
libre-échange journaleux classe moyenne
de plus riches au monde on a le niveau
de deux romans le chiffre le plus élevé
au monde
on a baissé le taux de criminalité dans
notre société au niveau le plus bas
depuis 50 ans les écrans plissement son
vrai ils sont concrètes ils sont
positifs mais j'ai échoué au clan de
communication mais c'est très clair en
tout cas ses freins on vous avait pas
entendu parler comme ça merci et on va
se reparler de la suite des shows de
cette course peut-être au leadership que
l'on voit venir très rapidement
merci à la prochaine merci et bon soir
au revoir